les serveurs sur en première c'est pas
un sketch armes longues heures samedi ce
qu'est qui en fait un petit sketch
j'aime bien je suis avec eux jeudi
goubert et lucie amen c'était les deux
personnes que je vais pour le rôle je
suis content que vous savez que on rit
on rit comme ça très timide
là c'est qu'ils sont en fait de faire le
connaître elle fait de le faire devant
la caméra c'est bien j'aime beaucoup
aussi un crédit cadre est pour le stress
de
les charmes sortir des choses qui m'a
jamais trop attirer des caméras donc
d'après tout ce qui est des plans les
machins les panoramiques les plans
américains je comprends rien en fait
donc pour cela mais tu fais vraiment
totalement confiance mais si c'est pas
bien et que jacques rigal simplement je
crois que je me transformais en dame
âgée mais j'ai pas tellement bien
compris comment parce qu'il ya des
naître des effets spéciaux qui font que
nous on est que comédien mais finalement
on est peu de chose on va tomber la fin
du sketch sur serveur c'est un plan
assez
compliqué à mettre en place pour pas
faire trop d'erreurs c'est pour ça que
je suis là je suis arrivé un petit peu
les effets visuels